we're going to start the news this
morning with something that is not good
at all here we go again you know this
story as we have too many times before
we're going to start with another deadly
mass shooting in this country it's a 146
mass shooting so far this year and we're
only 101 days into the new year think
about that for just a second there are
only so many ways to say the same thing
over and over and over again this time
we're talking about the people in
Kentucky they are grieving after man
killed five people and wounded eight
others inside the Old National Bank in
downtown Louisville now police say the
shooter was live streaming the attack
before officers shot him to death the
five people who were murdered all worked
for the bank they are 57 year old Deanna
Eckert 40 year old Joshua Barrick 63
year old Thomas Elliott 45 year old
Giuliano farmer and 64 year old James
Tutt Roxanna siberi has made her way to
Louisville for us a downtown area not
far from the Waterfront not far from the
ballpark there would be a beautiful
spring day but I'm thinking of the
families of those five victims who woke
up yesterday with them and wake up today
without them Roxanna good morning
Tony CBS News has term the shooter was
armed with a semi-automatic AR-15 style
weapon and had worked at Old National
Bank behind me as an intern for three
Summers before becoming a full-time
employee in 2021. police searched his
home last night while investigating why
he would come to work and kill some of
his colleagues
shots rang out at Old National Bank
shortly after 8 30 Monday morning
another caller advising possibly eight
to nine people have been shot within
three minutes of receiving 9-1-1 calls
police rushed to the scene
after exchanging gunfire they killed the
shooter police say the gunman
25-year-old Conor sturgeon was armed
with a semi-automatic AR-15 style weapon
and worked at the bank which was closed
during the attack he's texted a friend
called a friend left a voicemail he's
going to kill everyone at the bank
stealing suicidal police are
investigating a possible motive this was
an evil Act of targeted violence all
five people killed were other employees
of the bank I just walked
right past the conference room where
everyone was
and then I came down and I had to grab
something and and I got up there and the
guy was like well there's a shooter we
were in the back conference room
whoever's next to me got shot and hit
Bloods On Me from it one of the victims
63 year old Tommy Elliott was a close
friend of Kentucky Governor Andy beshear
Tommy Elliott helped me build my law
career
help me become governor
gave me advice on being a good dad
nine people were transferred to the
hospital including two officers
responding to the scene one of them is
26 year old rookie Nicholas Wilt who
graduated from the police academy less
than two weeks ago he was shot in the
head our lmpd officers went into that
building knowing that they were risking
their lives to say their lives to save
other lives
and that's exactly what they did
[Applause]
world is in critical but stable
condition after brain surgery at the
University of Louisville Hospital three
other injured patients have already been
released from the hospital Gail
Roxanna we thank you